for as little as 20 years ago I think
it's unlikely the world would have been
so welcoming to the news that the prime
minister of the day was to have a child
with his latest girlfriend having had
four with his newly divorced wife and by
repute possibly a couple with other
girlfriends what's even more remarkable
this is a Tory Prime Minister and no one
in the Tory party seems to care it is a
dramatic change from 20 or 30 years ago
when such events would have led to a
grass roots abelian in the party
particularly amongst the blue mince
women who played such a powerful part in
the shire conservative associations
remember this was the party who for
settled Parkinson to resign as a cabinet
minister because he'd had an
illegitimate child with his new
girlfriend and it was also the party who
didn't elect Michael Portillo the strong
favourite as their leader because he
revealed he'd had a homosexual
relationship while a student we all know
moral attitudes have changed beyond
recognition but every so often something
happens which just demonstrates a scale
of that change so I agree with you and I
do think it reflects a change in
attitudes and what is socially
acceptable these days and I support that
because I think that you know this whole
judgemental view of what constitutes a
family and what constitutes this is okay
but you're you're not okay
for a very long time it's been very
rigid so I actually like the fact that
kind of expectations have softened and
lowered and that anything is kind of
fine
to some degree I guess I haven't liked a
lot of the personal scrutiny and comment
and judgment in the press I think it was
Alastair Campbell was tweeting poor kid
and I just think all of that is a little
bit much and I don't I don't know why so
many people feel a need to pile in with
personal judgment on someone else's
private life that made me feel
uncomfortable but yes I agree with you
and I think that it's a good thing well
things have changed
that that said that in 2017 48.1%
of children born in this country were
two parents who either weren't married
or in a civil village and that seems to
me a simple partnership is a good thing
it is what it is I mean I can I can
hardly sit and say it's a bad thing I
had two children out of wedlock for a
long time my children all seem to be
having children out of wedlock so who am
I to criticize and I think it's just
something a fundamental change that has
happened and it happens and politics is
always last to catch up with these
things but they've now caught up with
this on the in terms of children being
born out of wedlock I was interested you
use the show you said expectations have
softened I think they've just become
more realistic I think that I don't
think it's often I think it is exactly
as most people live their lives and just
to pick up what I thought and I really I
really support you on this look Boris
Johnson it is I can say it's old enough
and ugly enough to look after himself I
think some of the opponent have been
directed to this has this woman's first
child right and I think some of the
coverage of her has been really ugly
negative and also misogynistic I want to
bring in a tweet from the Labour MP
Florence a shallow me who said very
convenient for this news to be announced
today
now obviously congratulations are to be
extended to a couple expecting a baby of
course but the timing is does it's
slightly galling because I think that
Boris Johnson is media managing us and I
find it annoying so I'd like to remind
you that on that day you know we had a
top civil servant alleging that he was
forced out and he's now pursuing legal
action we had all kinds of rumors about
you know bullying and harassment culture
in the treatment of the civil service
and we had reports of a potential hit
lists that the government had four
permanent secretaries in the Home Office
and the Treasury No
what is annoying to me I think is that
we are being media managed you know the
Boris Johnson is playing the public for
fools and my I just wonder how long
we're going to put it didn't work today
I mean because both stories became very
big stories and bosses came and went
actually I'm like you I congratulate
them exciting moment in their life but I
don't think the I think they probably
didn't try to media manager didn't work
the media picked up on it I mean the
media was you know they would have made
Pravda proud the way that they covered
this baby they also picked up on pretty
/ - it did mean that there was
competition for the front page the
following day and the baby did win and a
lot of and a lot of so yeah I use you
genuinely believe that that was put out
just because of that well the fact is
when did they find out I just it's like
we've never had immediate media
management I mean you know the Labor
Party in a way probably took it to his
absolute peak and I put that word in
quotes that the good day to bury bad
news if you recall that back on 9/11 so
all parties have been guilty with it but
but Greg that's what I couldn't believe
you could keep a straight face as you
were saying because they've all done it
but Greg is Greg's point is the absolute
ceiling the crowning glories it didn't
work the story is out there we'd better
say as we've mentioned the Home
Secretary by the way that this is what
the Minister of the Cabinet off is
effectively the DPM Michael Gove has
said about this the Home Secretary
absolutely rejects these allegations the
Prime Minister has expressed his full
confidence in her and having worked
closely with the Home Secretary over a
number of years I have the highest
regard for her this government always
takes any complaints relating to the
ministerial code seriously and in line
with the process set out in the ministry
or code the Prime Minister has asked the
Cabinet Office to establish the facts
but again Greg I think that's the story
it's going to run and run as well you
don't think that expressing confidences
it's a bit like the
I'm gonna psyche him next week from what
Philip Ratnam said he said one of my
duties is permanent secretary was to
protect the health safety and well-being
of about 35,000 people this created
tension with the Home Secretary and I
have encouraged her to change her
behaviors I have received allegations
that our conduct has included shouting
and squaring belittling people and
making unreasonable demands behavior
that created fear we're actually
resigned because of course he also had
issues reportedly with amber Rudd as
well and that was also the department
served information so amber rod lost her
job someone working to you consistently
produces dud information the work is
substandard what do you do
shouting will not be what do you do it's
a change your as a change your behavior
change your performance otherwise
because their workplace isn't a single
entity so what works in one place to one
collection of people would be
ineffective in another so I would argue
that a fast-paced high-pressured
breaking news environment you're going
to be communicating and communicated to
differently to what you would be in say
a tech startup in shortage it's going to
be a very different style of management
and all as a manager are your job is to
a few is to communicate effectively to
get the best out of your workforce and
if shouting achieves that in your sector
and field and people respond to that
constructively well that's up to you if
you're in a sector where it really is
innovative then as a manager you've got
to be able to manage your styles that
work for people I think that is
absolutely wrong I think that I think
that you should there is there is no
for shouting in any workplace but even
on its own terms Michelle that's
incorrect because as it turns out the
civil service does not respond well to
bullying and being shouted we have union
leaders say that the the atmosphere in
the civil service is what you said that
was wrong which is that even on its own
terms you're saying there's some
environments in which that works there
is it doesn't work for simple that
people perform better when they're
valued in kitchen ever work but there
are some environment and that's where it
is very